firstly is Liz trust safe as prime
minister
it's just got the support of the
government it's really important that
this time that we have stability that's
what the chancellor has been talking
about that's what we're focused on in
government and that's why I think your
viewers at home expect of us you know
they're worried about their mortgages
they're worried about their energy costs
uh the last thing they want is more
politicians talking about themselves
let's say to colleagues we've got to get
behind the Prime Minister work with the
new Chancellor put in place the right
medium term financial plan that we need
and then move from there at the very
beginning of and we spoke to Robert
Halford who was pretty clear he was
worried he said talking to his
constituents who were frightened about
what was happening to the economy he
said that the current government looked
like you were blowing up not only the
conservative party but the country and
he effectively said that Liz truss has
got days to set out a new approach and
to convince his colleagues and also the
country that you've got a grip do you
accept that yeah my constituents is
worried too who who wouldn't be I mean
we've got a war on European soil people
have seen the turmoil in the markets and
that's why the prime ministers acted and
of course it's right that the government
looks like and is focusing on on what
really matters to people stability the
energy price guarantee that we don't
talk enough about because it's a really
big intervention it's bigger than the
furlough I mean this affects every
single household every business for this
winter it's got a cost of around 100
billion which is one of the reasons why
we're having these conversations in such
a profound way but you've got to control
what you can control and what I and
other ministers can now do is work
really diligently night and day for the
next two weeks bring forward the plan
that will give us the stability and
confidence that we all need so did you
get it wrong then you know you announced
as you said this big spending energy
policy 100 billion pounds at the same
time as tax cuts at the same time that
you were saying you're going to be
sticking to the same withstanding
envelope was that wrong yeah for sure
there's things that I think everybody in
government would regret over the last
week and that's why the prime ministers
made changes but what we didn't get
wrong and remember that's why we had to
act when we did a head of energy prices
going up on the 1st of October was that
energy price guarantee that's that's why
the the growth plan came forward when it
did and what's not wrong is to focus on
economic growth you can't just tax or
spend your way to growth so the prime
minister's always been right about the
focus on economic growth going forward
so you're right on the energy price
guarantee you're right on the focus on
growth what were you wrong about well
the rate of which you you could proceed
and as the chancellor said yesterday not
involving the OVR in those conversations
I think it was it was well meant to act
as quickly as possible but clearly that
that has caused some of the turbulence
most of that is due to global factors I
agree with your previous guest uh
Charlie Bean about three quarters of all
of the movements can be explained uh by
global factors but but that was wrong we
fixed that now and there's a real job of
work over the next few days and weeks
not long to wait about how we can lay
out a budget and give people the
certainty and confidence they need why
was quasi quat unsacked
well as I say the Prime Minister
um concluded that the right thing to do
was to make a change it's not it's not
what anyone wants uh when people in
Westminster are talking about
Westminster Sophie I've got constituents
like Robert yeah people up and down the
country are worried come on who the
chancellor is and the reasons that the
chancellor was sacked after you know a
month in the job that is all about
policy people can be looking at the
Judgment of the Prime Minister and
thinking what on Earth is going on here
and the prime minister's exercised that
judgment she's brought in a new and
really experienced um Chancellor someone
um that's got a business background uh
that understands uh how you grow an
economy he set out some of his
priorities but but now we need a little
bit of time to do that work no one wants
those decisions to be rushed I
understand everyone wants uh decisions
about what's going to happen immediately
but we also want them to be right and we
want the obr to have a proper chance as
we said that was something that did that
didn't go well
um we want to give the obr proper chance
to look at those figures and I want to
look at a bit more about what you like
to do in a moment but first just to look
at the resignation say a resignation
letter it wasn't really a resignation
was it the letter from quasi-quarting in
response to his sacking and I just
pulled out a couple of things here your
vision of is it to the Prime Minister
your vision of optimism growth and
change was right I believe your vision
is the right one we have responded to
those those events since we set out the
growth plan I mean it's pretty clear
looking at this letter from the
chancellor that he thinks that this was
the prime minister's Vision that he was
enacting and you can see why can't you
they were in lockstep together
and um we've all we're all in agreement
actually on the fundamental challenges
that we face which is this country needs
a greater rate of Top Line growth we
need to improve some of the workings of
government that just make everything
everything so slow Sophie it takes too
long to get the infrastructure built
it's too hard to get affordable child
care
um there's broad agreement around that
now any government is is a combination
of people working together trying to do
their best uh not always getting
everything right and it's up to the
prime minister to make those judgments
about how best to configure her team but
if everyone as you say you know you
agreed on on the strategy uh and quasi
quarantine thinks that he was enacting
the vision of the Prime Minister why was
he sacked was he sex his prime minister
who should be going in that case isn't
it no look this is a time when we need
stability I don't think anybody would
say that
um what the the country needs right now
is either more change inside the
Westminster bubble nor a labor
government that will actually come
forward and give more rights to the
Striking workers that are a real break
on people's ability to go to work
nationalizing energy companies or as
mayor Khan says taking us back into
Europe all of those things would
increase the level of uncertainty and
people at home are just tearing their
hair out with that level of uncertainty
what they want to see is competent
government getting on with the job
that's and that's what that's what
exactly what we're going to do although
if you look at the polls what people at
home want to see is the labor government
well I I think what they actually want
to see that's a reaction to uh what's
been going on over the last couple of
weeks what they actually want is calm
they want stability and they want
confidence that's what the economy needs
as well okay um I just want to play you
a clip from the US president we've seen
it this morning I'm sure we've already
seen it but just for people at home this
is some comments from Joe Biden in an
ice cream parlor in Oregon let's just
listen to what you had to say and then
get your reaction
he was talking about the uh lizros plan
um he was overheard in an ice cream
parlor in Oregon saying well it was
predictable I wasn't the only one who
thought it was a mistake
I mean he is clearly talking about some
of the government strategy there
well as I say I didn't actually hear
that we didn't have the chance to uh to
see it on VT either
um the IMF who haven't been the the
biggest supporter of this government
actually did say that economic growth is
the right thing it's what every country
uh should be focusing on uh and I think
that's very hard to disagree with that
the government spends uh literally
hundreds of billions of pounds a year of
people's money
um there's always scope for that to be
improved and the UK economy hasn't grown
at the sort of rate that will give us a
sustainable NHS sustainable high quality
Public Services now an increase in
defense spend the only way of squaring
that Circle if you're not just gonna tax
hard-working people more which is not
the conservative way is to get the
economy to grow a bit faster I'm going
to try one more time to play the clip
because I appreciate it's difficult to
respond if you haven't heard let's have
a listen
well it's predictable I mean it was I
wasn't the only one that thought it was
a mistake yeah
but look she uh
but I think that uh
the idea
cutting taxes on the super wealthy at a
time when
anyway I just think I I disagree with
the policy but that's up to Great
Britain to make that judgment not me
it's talking about cutting taxes some
ice cream he's got this yeah it's a
healthy ice cream and what do you make
of that though I mean you were as you
say you were in the treasury at the time
these decisions were being made cutting
taxes were super wealthy at a time for
economic growth the message that sends
out is so damaging and and that message
has changed but
Sophie 98 of that package which I regret
the fact
um that we've not talked enough about
that was the nigh on 100 billion a year
intervention to help to help you've
already spoke about the energy people
package uh Robert Half an uh earlier
asked Liz trust to apologize to his
constituents you've admitted some of
your constituents were frightened you
talked about soaring mortgage rates I
just don't understand why you don't just
come out and say look I'm really sorry
we got that badly wrong well effectively
I have I mean you can put different
words in my mouth but effectively
effectively I've said that but what I've
also said will you apologize then to
people who are seeing the mortgage rates
arises that we're looking at
the mortgage rates in the UK are very
similar to the mortgage rates in the US
and last time I looked we don't run the
U.S policy so this is something that is
happening globally of course I regret
the fact that mortgage rates are rising
for anybody that's that's a really
challenging thing and what the
government's going to try and do both
through its innovation in energy I know
people don't want to talk about that but
that is that is the vast the vast amount
other things of the decisions that the
government have made is that energy
price guarantee that's giving people
confidence and certainty it's why
frankly some of the other elements of
that package which became a distraction
uh we had to move on from because it is
really important that people understand
that it also reduces the rate of
inflation so forecasters say that that
will reduce the rate of inflation which
is one of the headwinds that people are
facing on the cost of living by about
five percent now that's really valuable
Joe Biden is not doing that in the
United States we are doing that because
we're a compassionate conservative
government that's trying to protect the
most vulnerable people
so you're not taking the opportunity to
apologize I've I think I've been at a
quite length Sophie to talk about things
that we would do differently but I'm
much more interested and I think your
viewers are much more interested in what
happens now okay going going to thank
you for the interview tips let's let's
talk about that now because uh the last
Wednesday prime minister's questions the
Prime Minister was asked if she was
sticking to her promise that she was not
planning public spending reductions and
she replied absolutely Jeremy Hunt
yesterday said we're going to have to
look at some very tough decisions on
both spending and tax all government
departments going to have to find more
efficiencies than they were planning to
so what is actually going on with
spending well I think spending will
continue to increase but perhaps not at
the same rate that it would have done
that's always an element of a of a four
so just to jump in there Chancellor said
there'll be difficult decisions that
need to be made again that's that's
fundamental I think we all understand
whether it's doing our household
economics or doing those for the country
that when you try and put a budget
together you do have to make some
difficult decisions so just just you
said spending will continue to rise but
not as fast as some were expecting
previously the government was said it
was still committed to the current
spending envelope from the comprehensive
spending review is that still the case
the chances have been very clear that
everything's in scope and I think I
think Sophie that's the right thing to
do so that's not necessarily true
anymore that you're committed to that
spending envelope everything everything
is in scope those are the decisions for
the Prime Minister and the chancellor to
make once they've seen where the
opportunities are the state spends 900
billion pounds a year so whilst it's
really important it's vital that the
government puts fiscal in fiscal
Prudence at the heart of its budget and
that's what is going to happen over the
next few weeks with the support of the
obr it's never true that there are no
decisions that can be made within that
sort of envelope can you commit to the
proposed three percent increase in
defense spending well inimical to the
fact I'm saying that everything is in
scope there are no commitments I'm
afraid that I can make um nine o'clock
on a Sunday morning because we're going
into a process I think In fairness you'd
be the first to say look why would you
be making decisions uh without taking
those into full consideration and
without of course involving the obr
which is something that I think all of
us have said that with hindsight would
have been nicer to to do now listening
to Jeremy Hunt yesterday it sounds a lot
like you know tristanomics is dead he's
talking about the need for fiscal
responsibilities spending restraints tax
Rises if necessary who's really in
charge here well he also said that he is
at one with the Prime Minister on the
big task facing our country which is if
we want to have high quality Public
Services we want to spend more on the
NHS we want to deal with some of the
really big issues in society like
decarbonization and have low taxes
that's going to make our economy
competitive then we're going to have to
have higher rate of economic growth his
words my words various different ways of
getting there and that everyone wants
growth well it's the same just it's the
same destination there'll always be I
don't think you see any government of
any stripe who said that they're not
they don't want economic growth the
question is how you get there and I have
to say Liz trust during that leadership
kind of pain Jeremy Hunt yesterday they
have got completely different Visions
even you would acknowledge that who is
the real prime minister don't we hunt
all this trust I I wholly disagree that
they have different visions and in fact
I think what unites the conservative
party is that we believe in a
competitive economy we believe in people
keeping as much of their own uh income
as they can we believe in low taxes but
we also believe in protecting the most
vulnerable and having high quality
public services so if we believe in all
of those things the only thing left to
reconcile is economic growth and we are
the party that wants to come forward we
want to improve the clock speed of the
economy these things they call supply
side measures are really real because
they are you know getting that local
Road built making sure there's a new
facility for your local GP those are the
sort of things my constituents are
worried about and just finally and I
know you want to talk about policies
rather than personalities but the papers
are full of speculation about potential
Unity candidates to replace Liz trust
quite an unusual on the front page of
the Sunday mail I'm not sure if you've
seen it but the front page of the Sunday
mail showed a picture of yourself saying
that you might be able to about to enter
number 10. I can give you an exclusive
that that is absolutely never going to
happen Sophie I think poor old big thing
I think poor old Ben Wallace has been
greatly greatly slandered if whatever
the term is but uh no
a very important job to do supporting
the chancellor on a serious note what
would you say to colleagues who are
looking to put Liz truss on notice who
are looking and having those
conversations trying to find a Unity
candidate they're worried about the
polls they're worried about the economy
and they think it's time for her to go I
understand the worry of of colleagues
they're all trying to do the best for
their constituents
um but if we want to be taken seriously
as a party seriously in the country we
have to unite we have to get behind the
Prime Minister you know Europe there is
a war on European soil people are facing
a really difficult cost of living
Challenge and they're really worried and
so they don't want to hear disunity from
the conservative party they don't want
to hear about another leadership
campaign we saw the damage frankly that
that did this summer they want us to
unite be serious and get back to work
and do what we've got to do over the
next couple of weeks okay thank you very
much for being on the program today
thank you